you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's programme
a warning of impending catastrophe in
madagascar as the island country faces
its worst drought in 40 years
lessons in nature how a new rewinding
center could help push biodiversity
around the uk
and the unexpected climate benefits of
volcanoes
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show
madagascar is facing the world's first
climate change famine with the united
nations warning that four years without
enough rain has devastated isolated
farming communities the island is the
only conflict-free country in the world
experiencing catastrophic levels of
hunger
well in a moment i'll be speaking to
unicef's deputy representative for
madagascar about what can be done to
help those starving because of climate
instead of conflict but first here's
more on what's happening
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well joining me now is jean benoit
madagascar deputy representative for
unicef welcome to you first of all just
how serious is the situation there
thanks man it's pretty serious because
we consider that
up to one million people can be affected
out of which five hundred thousand
children
and i mean there are several droughts in
the south but what makes this drought
special is the scale of course the fact
that third drought in a row the fact
that
in addition the country has been
weakened by kovid
and there's growing insecurity economic
crisis which makes the
support more complex than usual
and is it clear that climate change is
responsible and if so is there a sense
of sense of frustration there at all at
the world's biggest polluters who've
contributed the most to global warming
it's a mix of course you do have a
climate change which makes doubt more
frequent more intense and happening in
places where it didn't take place before
but there's also a local environmental
degradation uh which accelerates and
aggravates the situation so i would say
that there's a definitive frustration
but we also need to work on the local
routes
and how concerned are you that if
climate change is responsible there are
going to be more events like this taking
place in future
there are going to be more events there
are already more events i mean we have
more cyclones we have cycle on this
place where there used to be no cyclones
we're more floods and we have more
droughts with uh aggravated impact uh
sand wind and so on and so forth so so
it's already there and um i think what's
worrying us is that local communities
have no choice but aggravating the
situation by copying with a little
resource they do have cutting trees over
using water and that's a kind of vicious
cycle that will not basically find any
easy solution at least in the short term
tell us a bit more about what is
happening as a result of climate change
what weather events is it producing i
would say that right now in omega's car
is attacked on all sides and you have
some even indirect events like the rise
of pandemics because we do have regular
plagues epidemics and plague is caused
by rodents we are living which are
living forest because of deforestation
so i would say it's a you know and it's
a good way to do it it's a perfect storm
right now where uh an island which is
already poor which is already vulnerable
is going to be more poor and vulnerable
more vulnerable um with i would say a
little direct responsibility into it
because uh well we are little producers
of uh of course um co2
jean-born noir manis thanks very much
indeed
welcome
in today's other climate news a study
has found fire weather the combination
of hot and dry conditions with the
potential to spark massive wildfires has
become more common in western america
over the past 50 years sacramento in
california has seen the number of fire
weather days almost triple it comes as
ten communities in the sierra nevada
region are under evacuation orders due
to the growing french fire there
more than a quarter of cars produced in
the uk in july were either electric or
hybrid electric
uk car factories made more than 126 000
alternatively fueled cars last month the
highest share on record that's despite
overall uk car production falling to its
lowest july level in 65 years
and indonesia may experience more
natural disasters in the coming months
according to the country's
meteorological agency the country's
monsoon season is expected to start
earlier and be more severe this year as
a result of climate change disasters
linked to the weather conditions could
include hail lightning and tornadoes
now when you think of the english
countryside an adidas image of green
rolling hills might come to mind but
diversifying how our landscape looks
through rewilding could play a crucial
role in tackling the climate crisis
it involves letting nature take care of
itself repairing damaged ecosystems and
restoring degraded landscapes and now a
new center is being launched to help
landowners learn about the practice
so why is it needed well at the moment
less than one percent of england is part
of active re-wilding programs now that
compares to approximately 70 percent of
uk land that's around 17 million
hectares which is used for agricultural
purposes
according to rewilding britain restoring
six million hectares of natural habitats
such as woodlands peatlands grasslands
and wetlands would store and capture
more than 10 percent of all britain's
greenhouse gas emissions
and a fifth of britain's species could
be saved from decline or extinction by
increasing the scale quality and
connections between habitats around the
country
well fraser hugill runs a mixed farm of
livestock and crops and has been
improving biodiversity through hedgerows
and wildflowers
but he says a specific center isn't
necessarily the answer to help farmers
rewild
i think it's quite a challenge around
venues in terms of you know how how will
people travel and and often landowners
and farms are quite busy so i think
there's a i'm not saying there's not a
role for it but i think if we want it to
be more widely spread it's you know what
can we do in in within locality
contractor ground control is behind the
wildfell center for environmental
recovery which is being launched and
their director is kim morish who joins
me now welcome to you
how important is rewilding and how much
of a challenge is it in a country that
has so large a proportion of its land
devoted to farming
how important is rewilding it vitally
important and as you mentioned earlier
just allowing the land to do nothing and
have a chance for nature to recover is
what so many of us should and could be
doing
when we purchased the
graze farm which we've renamed the wild
fell center for environmental recovery
most of it was used for for pasture and
for farming of crops many of which were
used to feed livestock we're going to be
moving to rewilding to setting up some
woodland creation by planting native
broadleaf trees
and it's just you know it's everything
that we can do to restore nature and
give it a chance to recover
and clearly there's an environmental
benefit to producing food locally is it
possible to
achieve a balance where that carries on
at the same time as rewiring enough of
the country as necessary
that's a great point of course it's it's
vitally important that we allow food to
be produced in the in the most efficient
ways and especially close to home
much of this land is already degraded
and is not the most productive for for
direct human consumption food sources so
we will we will be picking and choosing
the land that we use for wilding and
tree planting and the rest we will look
for more ecological ways to farm
and it's a center the best way forward
how practical is it for landowners up
and down the country to travel to your
site
well it's not necessarily a center for
people to travel to it's a center where
we can do research
evidence-based approaches to rewilding
and carbon sequestration through tree
planting and then share that as a
roadmap so while it's wonderful to see
it it's more getting the knowledge and
the learning that we can share with
anyone who has property whether that's
20 square meters or 2 000 hectares
that's what's missing is opportunities
for learning and so whether that's live
or just through knowledge based sharing
that's what we're hoping to achieve
kim morish thanks very much indeed
volcanoes are responsible for both
emitting and removing co2 from the
atmosphere stabilizing temperatures at
the earth's surface that's according to
research which looked at their impact
over the last 400 million years and
found that they act as a safety valve
for the earth's long-term climate and
while volcanoes won't solve the
human-induced climate crisis they might
be able to play a small part in helping
address global warming so here's how
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and finally thousands of spider crabs
have been spotted in knee-deep water
just a few metres from a popular cornish
beach the crustaceans gather every year
between the late summer and early autumn
to protect themselves from predators
during the malting process populations
of spider crabs are thought to have
thrived in recent years as a direct
result of climate change and warming
ocean temperatures
well that's everything from us for today
coming up next time as bags are packed
and tents assembled ahead of reading and
leads this weekend we're looking at the
climate impact of festivals you can find
out more tomorrow here on sky news
thanks for watching
[Music]